first Trump was as bad as Hitler then he
was worse than Hitler now he's worse
than Hitler Mao and Stalin combined
Trump is as destructive a person in this
century as Hitler Stalin and Mao were in
the last century he may be responsible
for many more million deaths than they
were
he needs to be contained but he needs to
be contained by attacking his policies
not his person
yeah attack his policies not his person
says this jackass
after saying Trump's deadlier than three
of the biggest mass murderers in history
but why stop there
wonder that Genghis Khan the Black
Plague Isis diphtheria lawn darts crib
death cigarettes climate change maroon 5
and the asteroid that wiped out the
dinosaurs he'll just go for it Trump is
responsible for more death than death
itself now after some outcry a CNN bride
Stelter admitted he should have hit back
blaming his meekness on tech issues
which I believe if his network hadn't
spent three years priming their guests
for this kind of hysteria the President
of the United States is racist all the
people who voted for Donald Trump yes he
is a racist pig reclaiming our heritage
that sounds a lot like a certain leader
that killed members of my family and
about 6 million other Jews in the 1940s
brother Trump is at this moment becoming
the American version of the Hitler and
Mussolini and just last week CNN accused
Trump of not aging a supernatural
augmentation directly related to his
inhuman callousness and now for the
115th time Stelter barfs out that
familiar refrain about trump's erratic
behavior getting worse there is
definitely a widespread recognition that
trump's behavior is getting worse in
type and in frequency it seems he's
acting more erratic more often we can't
tiptoe around it anymore we've got to
talk about this come on what was the
last time Stelter was able
to tiptoe around anything there's got to
be a new phrase to replace jumping the
shark for CNN
maybe it's called losing viewers by the
buttload because the problem with the
shrinks opinion about Trump's murderous
footprint isn't that it stood out from
this pack of braying hyenas but that it
didn't stand out at all he wasn't trying
to shock Stelter he was auditioning for
his job do I smell no I was just
checking do you thank you I think I
smell I think I might have a little body
odor I walked here three miles and
disgusting I smell gross and I think
I've let everybody down here I can smell
myself usually you tell us that Fox and
Friends had fish for really yeah I'm but
I don't smell anything so I I didn't
smell their fish I don't smell you want
no person could be this evil so it kind
of like throws their entire opinions
under the bus because they're so
hysterical unless you think Trump is
worse than Hitler Stalin and Mao no I
don't but I also I'm not a shrink I'm
not a shrink yeah I don't have any
opinion on this but I do think that in
terms of what we do which is political
commentary that yeah his policies and
his words they can be hurtful they can
be damaging and I'll say so I mean when
he says stuff about Jews being disloyal
I think that's pretty weird when he says
like over the weekend Obama lost Crimea
I think what he did he said Melania
got to know Kim jong-un very well and
and they got along great and then
there's the staff consensus I know they
never met actually and you think what
why'd the president say that so things
like that you make you think well his
policies his words his actions they were
that's those are like those are we we've
known P three years
truck Trump makes these fibs to help
create a directional truth like things
are getting better with Melania and
whatever this whatever that but we all
go that we get it that's not being
Hitler no I will say that we're gonna
get to Joe Biden and not knowing what
you're talking about I believe the next
segment so
to lead with Trump on that I'd say the
more they hate him the less they
understand him it's they they can't
unpack the way he talks why he talks
that way that he's part comedian part
news critic unfazed by the norms
larger-than-life personality and
president who is unjust the things that
normal people react to he doesn't react
to he doubles down on and then challenge
them them on it and he's willing to
think outside the box on a number of
issues I mean but but to the point about
death and number of people killed okay
this guy did crush Isis also you want to
talk about saving lives no one no one's
hoping that anyone passes away but if
there were to be one more Supreme Court
justice
he might just nominate the next justice
that will overturn roe v-- wade and then
we might actually save million born
lives Wow that's it which would be a
welcome development in this country save
more lives than any president ever be a
welcome development if you want a civil
war in this country alright let me bring
Dana you were gone for quite a while it
seemed like forever one of the things
that we talked about is why do these
young people think that socialism isn't
a problem but partly if you start
talking about history in a way that
doesn't actually accurately describe
what happened in history you will water
down people's knowledge of it and then
pretty soon they just think that like
there was some guy and yeah like they're
just like these guys from history so the
comparison not only is completely unfair
but it also is destructive if you're
trying to if you care about people who
learning history yeah and also dr. to
the idea of diagnosing what I mean a guy
saying something like that he's a
psychiatrist
should he be disbarred and perhaps in
prison for life completely reasonable I
have to agree with Dana these are
useless exercises of moral Reiger saying
these things and completely blunting the
horrific actions of our past anything
that Trump has said or done does not
parallel what we've seen with Hitler
Stalin and Mao
however Pete and I talked this two years
ago the whole Goldwater rule when it
comes to psychiatrists publicly
commenting on public figures when they
haven't actually treated them it is
unethical and they're not allowed to do
it and if you actually listen to this
interview it was so embarrassing
ridiculous because he was actually
saying we should not be criticizing
Trump we should not be calling him crazy
because that is really adding to the
stigma for mental illness but he said
the word crazy no less than 25 entire
interview and he said oh and by the way
anyone who votes for Trump is crazy so
he just played into his own thing yes
ridiculous I have a theory can I throw
it out to the people here okay who in
the media most helped elect Trump in
2016 wasn't Fox News we were having our
own internal civil wars here over
candidates because we had so many to
pick from and then the five was like a
microcosm of that we were arguing but in
the media CNN and Morning Joe both
devoted almost most of their political
time media time to trump and now there
his Spanish Inquisition my theory is
that they they are trying to make up for
what they've done because they elected
him and now they're doing all of this
because they feel tremendous guilt even
though sucker Jacques even though sucker
admitted no sucker admitted that they
kept remember they did Trump because of
the ratings yeah and they got him
elected I mean we put on his rallies
everybody put on his rallies without
question right we focused on all the
candidates making I don't think we put
on rallies for Jeb Bush the way we put
him on what it is a lot it is very
entertaining I don't know that I fully
understand your theory to be honest it's
a did it go over your head yeah I take
the example of the chosen one we said
well I am the chosen one and they went
nuts about him having a Messiah Complex
right when he's merely stating something
differently that is a fact
previous presidents have not stared down
China it's fallen right in his lap he's
a businessman who understands the
dynamics and he's taking him on but no
he was also and then he said later he
said obviously I was joking and I think
that they've kind of lost their ability
to have a sense of humor I mean look we
talked about his words but you can also
talk about his policies separate
family's a useless wall I mean I wonder
why it's useless because people keep
blocking it and who was separating
before Trump a person named Obama Oh get
out distorting okay stop it Juan stop
calling me names